all over the world bee populations are
decreasing it's a worrying trend because
bees are the most important pollinators
of many wild flowers and agricultural
crops disease may be causing some
colonies to collapse but recent research
shows that chemicals in pesticides are
also harming honeybees and this is
backed up by a new study on bumblebees
at London's Royal Holloway University
working my lab is building on previous
work looking at neonicotinoids the
systemic pesticides that are used
extensively in agriculture at the moment
and what we're doing is we're looking at
the effects of multiple pesticides not
just the neonicotinoids but also
pyrethroids which is the sort of
situation that these are faced with in
the field they visit multiple crop
species which may have different
pesticides applied to them the bees were
exposed to low levels of these
pesticides for four weeks they lived in
small colonies in the lab but they were
able to go outside via a long tube
connected to the window this allowed
them to collect pollen from real flowers
as they would in the wild while Richard
kept a close eye on their foraging
behavior the bees all have an individual
ID radio frequency identification tag
stuck to their backs each one of those
comes with an ambiguous number a unique
ID each time a bee leaves the colony is
registered by a particular reader an
RFID reader when the bee comes back
again it gets read by the same readers
and we can tell the identification of
each and every bee that goes out and
comes back and we know the exact time
that they've spent outside in the
environment
what we found is that this sort of
chronic exposure this long-term exposure
to low levels of pesticide is affecting
the behavior of individual bees and
therefore the performance of colonies so
we're seeing that link and those that
were exposed to both pesticides
consistently perform the most poorly in
all of our measures but the most
interesting findings perhaps are that
the near next annoyed Amanda clock rate
affected foraging performance of workers
so the ones that the colonies that were
treated with that pesticide actually
more forages but those forages were much
less effective at bringing back pollen
which is a limiting factor for colony
growth it's certainly concerning that
having these combination of pesticides
outside could be causing such a severe
impact but we know we've only looked at
two pesticides yeah we know that there
are hundreds of pesticides used out
there millions of areas of agricultural
land are being sprayed with these
pesticides and these bees are being
exposed to them currently pesticides are
actually regulated very tightly but the
focus is very much on what are the
lethal effects so what dosages will kill
bees and particularly honeybees are the
focus of those tests what I think our
study shows is that longer term effects
of lower doses can also be important so
they may be relatively subtle effects on
behavior but their effects on the
individual bees which filter up to the
colony level and can have effects on
whether colonies actually thrive or even
fail you do get a personal feel with
them and especially when you're seeing
them get affected so badly by these
pesticides you're thinking what really
is going on in the world and and you
know are they really being affected this
badly for me it is vital I mean these
are fascinating creatures they're
massively important in the ecosystem so
we can't lose them
you